let go Frieza  [Music]  and now for the little brat  [Music]  now there you  dear  okay for that what  Oh dad  gohan take piccolo with you and head  back to earth now hurry Gohan before I  lose what little sense of reason I have  left  [Music]  get down you brought this upon yourself  Frieza though I have to admit I didn't  see it ending quite like this yes you  say it I'm going to make my way back to  earth you could stay here and suffer the  same fate as this planet  how can you beg for mercy how many  people begged you for mercy before you  slaughtered them how many  [Music]  I've given you just a little bit of my  energy that's all you get you're on your  own which is being in the universe that  is why  [Applause]  [Music]